alguna vez has estado ahí hurgando en el
baúl de tus recuerdos y de repente te
encuentras una foto de tu pareja quizá
de esa pareja que tuviste hace años y tú
sabes que hay parejas que te dejan
grandes aprendizajes de vida grandes
lecciones pero también a veces ves fotos
de tu ex pareja y dices cómo pudo haber
andado con esto vueltas con tus amigos
con tus amigas le reclamas como me
dejaron dicen que hay ex es que son como
una vaca en un techo no sabes cómo
semejante animal llegó tan alto sin
embargo siempre hay lecciones en todo
fíjate yo tengo la filosofía de que el
amor te enseña mucho y de la forma más
inesperada todo lo que yo aprendí del
amor lo aprendí de un pan tostado con
mantequilla para ser más preciso de un
pan tostado con mantequilla y miel dicen
que cuando una persona no fue la
correcta para una relación quizá fue
porque fue la necesaria
tu evolución y si tú has pasado por
momentos inesperados puedes aprender
mucho cuando preparas un pan tostado con
mantequilla del amor 7 el pan es el
alimento predilecto para los desayunos
en muchas partes del mundo el pan ha
sido durante siglos utilizado para
montar desayunos y la gran razón detrás
de por qué el pan es tan versátil es por
su capacidad de carga un pan tiene en
promedio 14 milímetros de espesor y en
estos 14 milímetros cuando se tuesta
puedes poner aquí huevo aguacate salmón
lo mismo ocurre con una relación pero
vas a necesitar ingredientes y fíjate
ellos tengo la filosofía de que a veces
la vida te manda los ingredientes más
inesperados toma el 2020 por ejemplo
cuánta gente inicio el 2020 pensando
este es mi año este año voy a viajar voy
a tener el trabajo que siempre estamos
que siempre ha estado esperando voy a
tener un trabajo mejor
quizás este es el año en el que voy a
encontrar el amor y yo sorpresa cuando
se vino la cuarentena ahí estabas tú
quizás pensando ya estuvo me voy a
quedar solo sola toda la vida con mis
nueve gatos la vida cambio el romance
cambio oye la gente que iba a trabajar y
que esperaba encontrar el amor en el
trabajo ahora estaba en home office la
gente que estaba estudiando ahora tenía
que conocer a alguien a través de clases
en línea y tú ya sabes recién levantado
recién levantada toda polonia queriendo
encontrar el amor por su mamá
qué tarea tan difícil yo he encontrado
que el amor es quizá más simple de lo
que nos imaginamos es más sencillo pero
las circunstancias lo vuelven complejo y
mira hace poco hice un experimento de
hecho estábamos en plena cuarentena
cuando yo decidí hacer un experimento
social en las redes sociales lanzó una
convocatoria para que la gente me
contara sus experiencias sus dramas sus
telenovelas personales dije vamos a ver
qué sale de esto quiero ver qué guarda
la gente sobre todo estando encerrada en
cuarentena y ya teniendo mucho la
atención una historia que se me quedó
muy grabada la historia de actriz astrid
era una mujer común y corriente que
estaba en sus veintes ella era feliz
tener una relación tenía cinco o seis
años con este novio con el que pensó que
había encontrado el amor por fin algo
salió mal después de esos seis años algo
curioso ocurrió y esta relación terminó
astrid ya sabes ahí andaba triste
pateando un bote pero de repente conoció
a alguien
y dijo me voy a dar un gustito tú sabes
justito hoy empezó una relación fugaz
duró meses quizá y esa relación tampoco
funcionó astrid se sorprendió cuando su
ex novio de 6 años regresó con ella y le
dijo mi amor vamos a intentarlo otra vez
sólo hay un problema justo cuando
decidió intentarlo otra vez con esta
nueva pareja
astrid recibió una llamada que acabamos
de hacer unos estudios médicos y resultó
que tienes un tumor y necesita
intervención en este momento estando ahí
en el quirófano estando ahí en la
plancha cuando los doctores decidieron
intervenirla se dieron cuenta de que el
tumor no era maligno pero había una
sorpresa más pastriz estaba embarazada
la mujer estaba sedada completamente
entonces los doctores hicieron lo único
que se pudieron imaginar buscaron a sus
seres queridos a su familia y le dijeron
su hija está embarazada a sus padres los
padres emocionados fueron con su novio
con el que llevaba seis años para
decirle vas a hacer papá
cuando astrid despertó y la mujer
recibió la noticia de que estaba
embarazada no tuvo más que llorar estaba
lloré y lloré y lloré desconsolada
porque hizo números y no le daban las
cuentas imagínate tener que llegar con
el amor de tu vida para decirle gordo si
estoy embarazada pero tú no eres el papá
dice que ella que tuvo que ir primero a
avisarle al papá biológico y cuando fue
con su novio de seis años con el que
había durado tanto tiempo el novio le
dijo quizá lo que muchos hombres muchos
novios responsables contestarían mi amor
no te preocupes lo que hiciste me duele
mucho yo sé que estás embarazada de un
hombre que no conozco pero aquí estaré
yo siempre para ti dice astrid esa fue
la última vez que supe de ese hombre
nunca se volvió a aparecer y te pones a
pensar y dices es increíble como hay
gente que vive situaciones que tienen
que ver con el amor que se vuelven tan
complejas
pudiendo ser tan sencillas lo que más me
llama la atención de esta historia es
que justo en esa transmisión que estamos
haciendo en vivo donde astrida estaba
contando todo esto aparece una niña de
como 7 años a darle un beso astrid y es
la niña era la niña de la historia la
niña que había salido de esa relación
nunca sabes nunca sabes cuándo de tu
situación más difícil de tu relación más
complicada pueden venir las más grandes
lecciones y las más grandes bendiciones
yo creo que el amor es más sencillo de
lo que pensamos y requiere de tres
ingredientes principales el primero
necesitas un pan de paciencia fíjate
para que un pan pueda tener la capacidad
de carga para hacer un buen desayuno
tiene que tostarse en promedio durante
tres minutos con 36 segundos y a una
temperatura de 154 grados centígrados
ese es el promedio pero tú sabes que hay
tostador es que tú están más rápido y
tostadores que tú estás más lento
es el tipo de vida el tipo de persona
que te va a tocar cuando llegas a una
relación y me llama mucho la atención
porque un amor una persona tiene que
pasar por tres tipos de amores en su
vida antes de llegar al amor verdadero
se dice que tienes que pasar por la por
el tipo de amor que te enseña a querer
por el tipo de amor que te rompe es el
segundo y el tercero por el amor
inesperado que es el verdadero estos son
dos factores necesitas tiempo y
necesitas calor
necesitas tus tres minutos con 36 y
necesitas tus 154° cada quien pasa por
su tiempo y por su temperatura diferente
y tú sabes que hay gente que el día de
hoy está soltero soltera y está
desesperada estas cosas tienen una
mística diferente entre marc las buscas
- te llegan y ahí estás tú todas tus
amigas andan con planes con galanes y tú
más de ignorada que comercial de youtube
no te llega ni una invitación el único
que te está marc márquez es el elástico
del calzón y empieza hasta desesperar te
empiezas a sufrir porque no te llegan lo
que tú piensas que es la felicidad en la
forma de una pareja no te desesperes
si estás en sequía de amores los que más
tardan en llegar los que se cuecen lento
son los mejores necesitas el pan de
paciencia y te voy a dar una sorpresa
eventualmente llegará quizá quién te
complemente quien sea tu otro pan pero
va a ser totalmente diferente a lo que
podrías esperar y vas a tener que
ejercitar la paciencia el pan de
paciencia quizá vas a llegar con tu
pareja un día y le vas a preguntar mi
amor qué quieres cenar te va a decir lo
que quieras gordo
bueno que eres sushi si no quieres pizza
decir no quieres tacos decir no vas a
preguntar entonces qué quieres en arte
vas a decir lo que quieras
y en ese momento tú nada más recuerda
mis palabras paciencia así es el amor
más de una vez vas a ver a tu pareja y
vas a decir dios gracias por haberme
mandado un ángel no lo quieres de
regreso ya llévatelo disfrútalo tú ya lo
disfrutamos todos paciencia el pan de
paciencia es quizá lo más difícil de
cocinar pero una vez que pasa por su
tiempo una vez que pasa por su calor por
su dificultad llega mira el tostado
perfecto y en ese momento estás listo o
lista para recibir el resto
y si estás soltero o soltera no te
desesperes ni renuncias a tus sueños
cuando menos lo esperas llega a alguien
que te hace comprar calzones nuevos
número dos fíjate bien importante la
mantequilla
y esto es esa habilidad que necesitas
para que las cosas se te resbale para
dejar ir lo que no sirve
para que el amor crezca tres cosas se te
necesitan resbalar lo primero tus
expectativas eso es lo peor que le
puedes hacer una relación nueva llegar
con tu pan cargado de expectativas la
gente no va a ser como te la imaginas ni
en carácter ni en personalidad ni
socialmente ni físicamente alguien ha
tenido un novio feo de casualidad
alguien que esté viendo esta te ha
tocado tener un novio una pareja una
pareja fría quizá en tu vida te va a
tocar alguien que no sea agraciado
físicamente y va a sellar con tus amigos
con tus amigos vas a preguntar a poco no
está bien guapo te van a decir es bien
lindo si te preguntan está bien guapo y
le tiene pedazos buenos a lo mejor la
cara ofende pero el resto del paquete lo
defiende no importa como venga esta
persona necesitas está mantequilla que
hace que se te resbale las expectativas
lo segundo bien importante es su pasado
todos vienen con una carga de pasado
todos venimos quédate con alguien con
futuro
porque pasado todos tenemos el número 3
y esto es bien importante tu orgullo ten
mucho cuidado porque el orgullo es algo
que viene en el ser humano como parte de
su adn a veces venimos con una crianza
basada en orgullo y tenemos que
despojarnos del orgullo para que una
relación funcione estate alerta de las
señales cuando una pareja está en una
discusión tu vas a ver físicamente las
cosas cambian en la mandíbula por
ejemplo se endurece cuando estás enojado
con su relajada y si en medio de una
discusión tu pareja empieza a hacer esta
forma mira la acepta asesina sabes que
hay problemas mantequilla mira que se te
resbale
si estás entre tener la razón y ser
amable con tu pareja siempre elige ser
amable número 3 la miel esto es un
ingrediente favorito
esta es la energía que le pones a tu
relación la atención darle su darle su
miel darle su champú sito de cariño
todas las relaciones necesitan miel
somos la generación que está
acostumbrada a las opciones cuando
estamos trabajando tenemos siete
ventanas abiertas en nuestro browser
siempre creemos que hay una alternativa
mejor este es tu pan dedicarle tiempo
dedicarle amor será sencillo será simple
pero es tuyo y si quieres que te dé la
verdadera razón por la cual todo lo que
aprendí del amor me lo enseñó un pan
tostado te cuento un poco de mí cuando
yo era joven niño tenía como 78 años
y mi familia pasó por una crisis
económica muy fuerte ya sabes que los
problemas a veces tenían como en tienda
departamental en abonos
uno tras otro tras otro llegó un punto
en donde nos quedamos sin dinero yo soy
el mayor de cuatro hermanos y nunca se
me va a olvidar en esa crisis el sabor
de mi pan tostado con mantequilla y miel
mi madre cuando no tenía dinero para
comprarnos algo de desayunar nos
preparaba el pan tostado con mantequilla
y miel y te voy a decir que es lo mejor
nos lo vendía con un amor como si fuera
la última maravilla que se hubiera
preparado y tengo que lo más interesante
de todo así no sabía también así no
sabía no sabía delicioso como si fuera
lo más gourmet que alguien hubiera
probado
ahí es donde aprendí que las cosas
cuando se hacen con amor
saben diferente el pasto no es más verde
del otro lado de la cerca el pasto es
más verde donde los rieles
así con el pan tostado de tu vida
dedícale cariño dedica la atención y te
garantizo que hasta la peor adversidad
de dejar una lección cuando las cosas se
hacen con amor
saben deliciosas
soy jorge lozano muchas gracias